Speaker 1: Let's go to Devin from Virginia. Devin
from Virginia. Welcome to the David Pakman Show.
Speaker 2: Thank you. Yeah. I want to talk about
my state and kind of like how it's not really
doing great specifically about them on fourth, and
I have to show my ID to access an adult website
called Pornhub. And now there are loopholes to
this. Like I can simply turn off my wi fi that can
access it. So it's a very flawed system where.
Speaker 1: If you turn off wi fi,
how do you access a website? Don't
you need the internet connection.
Speaker 2: With my data on my phone? Oh.
Speaker 1: I see what you're saying.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So yeah, so it's
the big loopholes and like VPN,
so it's not really effective
and it's like very dangerous,
right? If you show your IP your porn
up, like it can easily be your ID can
be stolen. So yeah, it's just really dumb.
Speaker 1: So have you and your friends
sort of like, figured out how to
get around this ID requirement?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. Like I said, VPN is, is
like search like thing on Google when it happened
and other things as well too. So yeah, it's like
it's not very effective. It's more dangerous
for people and for children. It's just like, I
don't know if it's like culture war protective
kids type stuff. I don't know. Now, thinking.
Speaker 1: Bigger picture other than difficulty
access, slight difficulty accessing porn, what
else don't you like that's going on in Virginia?
Speaker 2: We'll see. I would say our governor,
like he he won based on us saying critical race
theory in our schools. Yeah. And that boosted
him and he won based off that. And I was really
disappointed with Virginians for sure, because I
thought would be smarter than that. I guess not.
Yeah, I know. It's just it's you know, it's
it's tough, you know, you thinking about moving
up? Yeah. When I'm able to have the funds for it.
Yeah, for sure. I would definitely like to move
maybe in Colorado and I would like to call. So.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, Devin,
we're sending you our best. Alright.
Speaker 2: Thanks. I appreciate a lot.
Speaker 1: All right. Devin from Virginia,
sticking it out. He's figured out how to get
the pawn, but still struggling with the governor.
That's. That's a situation. That's for sure.